hey guys Ryan right here couple hours
ago a new TV spot for Avengers age of
Ultron dropped when I talk anymore
actually he's the boss I just paid for
everything design everything
the vengers how can you possibly stop
- what we got
nice
ah
Richard
we didn't see that coming
Wow I already bought my IMAX tickets for
like 9:30 in the [ __ ] morning because
all the kids these were sold out Wow
the more you know like the more I see of
this the more excited I actually get
this really really showed us that
there's a big sense of humor within
these characters I liked those trailer I
remember Mortal Kombat was like one of
the first trailers to do it where they
were like Kaito
Liu Kang and I like when they do that
with Iron Man Captain America Black
Widow Thor there's so many cool shots in
this trailer when Captain America does a
front flip off of a motorcycle and then
Chuck's the motorcycle etic car that was
pretty [ __ ] sweet and like when Thor
like kicks up Captain America shield and
then it's like a baseball bat and takes
up some old front soldiers or whatever
now one points Black Widow was like hey
big guy to the Hulk back into big green
cocky and I'm glad they gave Hawkeye
like the cheesy powerful line of if you
step out that door you're an Avenger
because whoever he's talking to at that
moment they're gonna become an Avenger
in that second they'll be really
disappointed if they don't
I think I've heard quick I'm not I don't
know that much about Quicksilver but I
think I heard Quicksilver with like an
accent I don't know it sounds kind of
rushing or whatever I'm sure you guys
know just tell me whatever the [ __ ] it
is because that that is sexy that Aaron
taylor-johnson he's one sexy
[ __ ] did you know he was in
Shanghai Knights played like the little
British kid [ __ ] weird it just looks
like an epic action piece you know like
Avengers one like led up to the ultimate
big battle this one seems like now war
has broken out and this is gonna take up
a large chunk of the movie yeah the more
I see the more excited I already got my
tickets
that's I do this anyway guys thanks for
telling me that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow me on Facebook Instagram Twitter
the social networks and on a side note
spider-man might be a black guy Terrence
Howard that's the way to go
I just want to do one shoutout Brian
Jones he said hey can you give my
channel a shout-out and he sent me a
video I guess it's a cover of rule the
world
okay so he kind of has a hunter s
Thompson outfit on while he sings this
really sweet song Brian Jones you can
serenade anyone you want any lady you
want although something tells me you're
yet nothing wrong with that but you get
any guy you want with that voice man
dude dude dude
try saying yo every [ __ ] you are